[Music]
spirit has
raised the shape in which it is present
to its own consciousness into the form
of consciousness itself
and it produces such a shape for itself
the artificer has given up the synthetic
effort to blend the heterogeneous forms
of thought and natural objects
now that the shape has gained the form
of self-conscious activity
he has become a spiritual worker
this short paragraph number 699
is a very important transition point in
a number
of ways there's actually a good bit
going on within this paragraph itself
that we'll
talk about in just a moment but
we can also say that in
starting this paragraph we have now
entered into the
penultimate subsection of the
penultimate
portion of the work that is religion
which is going to be
succeeded by the very short absolute
knowing which will bring the entire
phenomenology
to a close the history of the
development
and self-understanding of consciousness
self-consciousness reason spirit
will be brought to a close and absolute
knowing
and religion is you might say the
the royal road to get there and this
section
um is sandwiched in between natural
religion which we've just traversed
and then the religion that hegel thinks
is the you know the sort of the most
developed
and in interesting one that is revealed
religion which we're going to be turning
to
judaism and christianity and
specifically to protestant christianity
and then we might call it
post-protestant
christianity that hegel is envisioning
which will then take us into absolute
knowing
but in between we have this what you
know miller is translating as
religion in the form of art the cuist
religion right which you could also just
translate as the art religion or
religion as
art which some of the other translators
have have chosen
for this section and you might say well
what's the connection between
religion and art okay that that's
something that we have to
explore throughout this section but you
know we can give a
couple highlights who's hegel talking
about
in this section it's really going to be
the greeks
and you know this is kind of you could
say
typical not just of hegel but also of
european philosophy
in general particularly in the 19th
century
there's this notion that you know the
greeks
and then you know by extension the
romans
are the highest level of you know
philosophical development
and in some cases other types of
spiritual development but then
judaism and christianity come on the
scene and add something new so we've got
this
long-standing conflict between athens
and jerusalem coming from the tertullian
equip
what does athens have to do with
jerusalem and the answer of course
is even just in the realm of ideas an
awful lot
but in the realm of real history way
more
so you know hegel is going to be
focusing primarily
on the greek city-states and greek
civilization
as producing something new and he's not
as i pointed out he's not
unusual or let alone unique
in doing so this is a very common thing
among europeans in the the 19th century
and hegel is kind of a leader
in that but he's far from the only
person
saying this sort of stuff i mean this is
a bit of a side note but it goes
down all the way to the 20th century
when you see somebody like martin
heidegger
saying that only greek and german are
truly philosophical languages
that latin french english we could also
say spanish italian
let alone any non-indo-european
languages aren't
adequate you know to convey this it's
typical of this
so when we're approaching this we can
we can relativize it i think to a
certain extent and say what are we
supposed to get out of this what is
hegel getting at here because obviously
the story that he's telling is at a
pretty high level of generality
so that's a little bit of
background stuff let's actually jump
into the paragraph
and look at what he has to say now so
there's a very interesting interplay
here
in this paragraph between two terms
that have come up a lot in the religion
section
one of these actually both of these have
been around the entire time in the
phenomenology but
one of these is gestalt shape right and
so
gestalt is bavusting shape of
consciousness
this is indeed what the entirety of this
work
has been developing a shape of
consciousness is a certain point in the
dialectic
where somebody is understanding
themselves the absolute
others the world through some sort of
uh ways in which things are formulated
we
generally how they're represented and
how their own agency or what they suffer
is connected with that right so we've
seen a lot of different shapes of
consciousness
we're seeing some now religion is also a
recounting the section religion
a recounting of different shapes of
consciousness hegel has told us at the
beginning
of the section and then we have this
other term form
right and form is the same in both
english and
german so we've got shapes we've got
forms
it's often uh attempting to translate
gestalt by
form but we don't want to do that we
want to say shape in this case
and the shape and the shaping
is going to be something that we can
see something tangible or a little bit
later
perhaps in this particular
subsection it'll be something that we
can
read or hear you know the epic poetry
for example
so we want to keep this in mind we also
want to keep in mind
that a a transition point was reached
in the end of the natural religion
section where we're moving
from the the arc meister the artificer
into somebody who is a genuine artist a
counselor somebody who's
producing works of
art which could be works of literature
also works in music as well
there's something new that's that's
happening here so let's
uh pick it up and he's talking in rather
abstract terms at the beginning
he says spirit has raised the shape in
which it is present to its own
consciousness into the form of
consciousness itself
and it produces such a shape for itself
so
what are we talking about there well
spirit is
when he says spirit has done this spirit
is acting
religion is a way in which
spirit through human beings becomes
conscious of itself and we've seen this
before
you know in the unhappy consciousness
when there was this
alienation of projecting the divine way
out there and i'm the miserable worm
over here
trying to relate myself to it
unsuccessfully
in the religion of art there's a much
stronger possibility of identification
as a matter of fact the gods become they
don't become
human as such you know but they become
much more human
like and there's there's a sort of a
double
side to this one is we can we can relate
to them a little bit more
you know um thinking about hephaestus
and uh the activity of working in the
forge and finding out that your
spouse is being unfaithful to you and
you know being a good mama's boy who
gets you know
hurt because of his dad throwing him out
of you know the heavens and stuff like
that
or being aries or being athena or
any of these other gods that we might
relate ourselves to
there's also the fact that
human beings for hegel
take themselves out of the natural
existence
and we do try to manipulate it to
assimilate it to change it but there's a
difference between nature
and culture that is
at the heart of what it means to be a
human being
it's not something that's that's fully
resolved and those gods are
similarly like that so spirit is
consciousness right it's as spirit has
raised the shape in which it is present
to its own consciousness
what is the shape in which is presence
to its own consciousness
well there's a double-sidedness to this
there's the shape as in the worker or
worshiper
sometimes the same person sometimes just
members of the same community
right those are a shape of consciousness
and then there's the shape the thing
that's been worked upon
by the work you know master the
artificer the through the
our bitin the the working of that person
and so there's the work as it is
produced we could say and that might be
a temple
that might be in the case of other
things in this section a poem
an ode to the gods it might be
an epic it might be a tragedy it might
be
a statue it might be some sort of
offering so all of these are
possibilities
for the way in which spirit is becoming
aware of itself what this means is that
in you know if we think about religion
in very materialistic terms we're
actually missing out on
what religion meant and does in fact
mean for
many people that it's a way in which we
could say the divine
through the human is becoming aware of
itself so he goes on and he says
we've got spirit is present to itself in
the form of consciousness
through this shape this gestalt
and then he goes on and says the
artificer the varkmeister
has given up here's an interesting thing
a synthetic
effort and that's the word synthetic
synthesis right uh to blend the
heterogeneous forms
of thought and natural objects what was
that about well
all the things that were happening in
the previous section
trying to take natural objects and
turn them into something that could be
an adequate bearer
of the divine and of consciousness being
conscious of itself
so he says now that the shape has gained
the form
of self-conscious activity
is very important the shape has gained a
form
of self-conscious activity that what is
self-conscious
activity is it activity where you're
like oh i better not screw this up
everybody's watching me no no it's
you're aware
of what you're doing of the contribution
that you're making
and of the ends that you have in mind
and
of perhaps the audience or
the god that you're trying to symbolize
in some way all of that could be part of
self-conscious activity
we should also remember that
self-consciousness
is self-consciousness for another
self-consciousness
so implicit in this is already
that this is for a community not just
for the isolated artist
by themself engaging in self-conscious
activity
and he goes on and he concludes this by
saying he has become a
spiritual worker geistiga right
somebody who can actually we might say
take
a greater agency in shaping the way in
which spirit understands
itself
if we ask which is the actual spirit
which has the consciousness of its
absolute
essence in the religion of art we find
that it is the ethical
or the true spirit this is not merely
the universal substance of all
individuals on the contrary since this
substance has for actual consciousness
the shape of consciousness
and it is individualized it follows that
the substance is known by the
individuals as their own essence
and their own work it is for them
neither
the divine essential light in whose
unity the being for self or
self-consciousness is contained
only negatively only transitorially
and in which it beholds the lord and
master of its actual world
nor is it the restless destruction of
hostile peoples
nor their subjection to a caste system
which gives the semblance of
organization of a completed whole but
in which the universal freedom of the
individuals is
lacking on the contrary this spirit
is the free nation in which hallowed
custom constitutes the substance of
all whose actuality and existence each
and everyone knows
to be his own will and deed
paragraph 700 of the phenomenology of
spirit is now
making a little bit more clear what we
have in mind in terms of this
religion of art the religion of the
artistic production
bringing the gods you might say or the
divine a bit closer
to humanity and hegel
very clearly has the greeks in mind as
reading ahead will
tell you but you can also see this here
in this
section in the way that he's handling
things and
i do have to remark that what's
happening here is at a very
high level of abstraction if you're
looking at
actual you know greek city states in the
way that say aristotle and theophrastus
did you know these great ancient
philosophers who thought that you needed
to
go to you know take a look at the way
things are actually
dealt with lived understood in each of
these
these societies that are held together
by this
essence of you know being part of part
of greece or you know a
hellenic mentality there's a vast
diversity between the different states
and you know there's also you know he's
going to talk about a caste system
and that this isn't a caste system but
that everybody is is able to participate
in it well that we know that wasn't the
case
because ancient greece like pretty much
every other developed society
had a lot of poor people and had slaves
and had
resident aliens and there you know
there's a lot more going on there but
let's put that aside for
the moment and see what he has to say so
this is a very startling thing to begin
with
he says if we ask what is the actual
spirit the virglika geist right the
actual or real spirit
which has the consciousness of its
absolute essence in the religion of
art right so the spirit that is getting
to know itself
through this artistic production and
contemplation enjoyment
all of those sorts of things what does
hegel tell us
we find it is here he has two different
predicates
the ethical zitlika or
true vara spirit
what does that mean to be the so the
true spirit
um you know truth in hegel is kind of a
complicated thing
he doesn't operate with anything
remotely like a correspondence theory of
truth
as a matter of fact he's often held up
as somebody who
although he doesn't endorse this
explicitly has what we call
a coherence theory of truth where you
have to understand things within the
totality
true spirit is going to be spirit that
is expressing itself
to the greatest extent that is that has
developed itself that it's at the end of
the
process or at least here in this case in
the middle
of the process getting us through this
section and then to
the absolute religion uh that of
revelation which is going to you know
uh sublate what we've got going on here
in a natural religion and then move into
absolute knowing
that but what is he talking about in
terms of the ethical spirit why
why return to the ethical the zit lika
especially after the last section of
spirit
was all about morality we know that for
hegel
um the you know the ethical and the
moral
are not precisely the same thing by the
way a little bit of a side note here
people who have read introduction to
ethics textbooks or you know go on to
websites or stuff like that they often
say well i know that there's a
difference between the ethical and the
moral
and they're you know not clear about the
fact that
yes there are distinctions that people
make between these two
they're not always the same some people
are like well you know the moral
is about codes and customs and ethics is
the science of studying it
for hegel it's actually the opposite
what hegel means by the
zit leaky the the ethical customs
fall under that it's the thing where you
know he talks about the ethical
substance of a
community morality is more individuated
more
rationalized more uprooted from this
you know basic sort of ethics that
communities have
so whatever you've read about ethics and
morality
put that on the side when you're coming
to hegel because you you might actually
have the wrong idea about how these are
related
so in hegel's phenomenology we we
encountered the ethical
already at a number of different places
i mean particularly in the spirit
section we began with the ethical order
and
that was in ancient greece as well and
we talked about the antigone
and all sorts of other cool stuff and
then that led us into
you know the noble and base
consciousness and state power
and all of these other things that
eventually get us to the enlightenment
and you know struggle between uh you
know faith and skepticism
and and eventually we get to the french
revolution and
put all you know we could think about
all those things there was also stuff
going on in the reasons section wasn't
there
we had all these attempts
for the individual to orient him or
herself
in relation to the ethical substance the
zakah zelpst
so you know the law of the heart and
frenzy of self-conceit
reason giving laws to itself all those
things were ways in which
spirit through individual human beings
and
their cultural matrices and productions
was trying to grasp
this universal substance of you know
ethics within a community
we can even say that there were similar
issues coming up in the morality section
so this is kind of an interesting thing
to say i do want to say one other thing
about this you might say
religion and ethics and again this would
be a product of
having read uh too many uh intro to
ethics textbooks or philosophy of
religion textbooks
or looking at too many uh superficial
websites religion and ethics two
different things you know you can't get
one out of the other or religious
religious ethics
you know those aren't real ethics those
are coming down from on high
you've got to put yourself in hegel's
time you know
there was this guy emanuel kant
before hegel right and kant has a book
called
religion within the limits of reason
alone and what are you going to find if
you actually read that it's mostly about
ethics
right all of these great religious
conceptions
were being transformed into ethical
conceptions
and a lot of some people were like let's
strip away all the supernatural aspects
of religion
just hold on to the ethical stuff which
is coming through
these you know ancient religious ideas
that now could be purified by
reason so there is a very strong
intrinsic connection
going back both ways between ethics
and religion and for the ancient greeks
this was indeed
the case for many of them you know a lot
of the ethical quandaries are worked out
by having the gods chew on them a bit in
dialogue or
you know other ways like that so you've
got to be a little bit careful
in thinking about that now let's jump to
the text so he says
this is not merely what is what is that
the ethical or true spirit the universal
substance of all individuals
so it is indeed the universal substance
of all individuals right
uh it's not merely that it's not just
that
so don't say well it's not that at all
it is that and that's part of what gives
us our grounding
so he goes on and he says on the
contrary
since this substance has for actual
consciousness the shape the gestalt
of consciousness and now here hegel says
something really interesting
and is individualized hegel uses the
term
individual right mean and this is taken
like right out of the the latin
um and is is there as kind of like a
lone word it's not
einsell you know it's not rooted in
einsell heights or
the insulin individuality that way
um it's it's this other term that he's
using to denote this
so this you know the shape of
consciousness the gestalt
is being individualized in who well
at the very least in the producer in the
artist the counselor the person who is
producing the work of art
but also we could say in the objects of
the works of art
uh the various deities gods demigods
that are all depicted in monsters right
and the worshiper the consumer
the user of this is also being
individualized as well what this
yields us he says
the substance the ethical substance the
universal ethical substance of
all of our community is known by the
individuals
now here's where he says as their own in
essence in their own work
not as the essence and the work of
you know the we all of us together
but he says yeah against
their own their own
as individuals so my relation to
the gods through using say a liturgical
hymn to apollo when we actually have
quite a few of these left you know
we know about these through antiquity or
through reading homer or
or watching you know a recitation of
homer or whatever it's going to be
it is my own it is not simply
me participating in well everybody else
is doing this
this is what mom and dad did and their
mom and dad did and the city does
it's becoming individuated so
we realize that this substance is known
as their own essence their own ways in
height
and their own work their own production
here hegel then says it's not this it's
this instead so let's go through these
what is it not each of these corresponds
to
either previous discussions in the
religion section or things that will get
discussed
in hegel's lectures on the philosophy of
religion so the first one divine
essential light
right it is not the divine essential
light in whose unity the being for self
of self-consciousness is contained only
negatively
only transitorially in which it beholds
the lord and master of the actual world
god is not just
the lord and master writ large whether
it be the master of the master slave
dialectic
or the lord and master who shows up at
many other points
in the work as well you know in the
unhappy consciousness
in the the uh reason section in the
spirit section
over and over again so it's not that
right
it's also not this restless destruction
of
hostile or hateful
right other people uh this domination
of one tribe or nation by another
imposing its
its religion and its gods on it you know
associating into larger and larger
complexes that's that may be going on
this may be going on but that's not
what's happening here in the religion of
art
he also talks about it not being a caste
system
constant in in in uh hegel's german
and so he definitely has something in
mind like
india i think in this case he says it's
not the subjection to a caste system
which gives the
semblance the appearance of organization
of a completed whole
but in which the universal freedom high
height of the
individuals is lacking
so you know what's wrong with a caste
system it looks an
awful lot like you know one big happy
family hegelian
organic state but the people within it
are not free they can't
they can't move from one cast to another
if they would wish to they can't
innovate they can't do anything that
would be
you know their own you could say
uh in this in this new stage
we do have the individual able to
think for themselves to innovate so he
goes on and he says this spirit the
spirit the
actual spirit of the religion is a work
of art the ethical or true spirit
this spirit is the free nation that's
freya folk
right um so you know as opposed to these
other
nations in
which now here miller's adding a word
hallowed custom right
um there's no hallowed actually like
highly again you know or anything
custom though is desita and this could
be translated as custom
ethical norms ethics itself
right this is the substance of
everybody and he says whose actuality
and existence now this is you know going
back to the previous paragraphs
outside of this section in previous
sections
the actuality of virtually height and
the existence dazing
these are terms that kept up coming up
in the the religion section
those are he says each and every one
knows this to be
his own will and deed so
there is a kind of ownership a kind of
taking responsibility
but also being given the privilege of
speaking for oneself
involved in this now again to close this
out
how realistic a picture is this of
greek religion and of
greek culture in antiquity it reminds me
very much
of hegel's dictum in the lectures on the
philosophy of history where he
criticizes the entirety of the east
for you know having realized that one
man may be free right
there's a lord and master but everybody
else is essentially under this despot
and then he says the greeks realized
that some could be
free right but not everybody and then
with through christianity and
specifically
you know uh protestant christianity
human beings have realized that all men
can be free right are all human beings
hegel's i think it is gendered language
in there perhaps
um so the greeks at this stage
in the religion of art are kind of where
hegel's presenting
european christian consciousness in the
late middle ages
as as attaining let's put that aside for
the moment there there is something that
he thinks is really important going on
here and this individualization
is central to it
you